[Music]
I'd like to welcome everyone to the
second in the Karl Taylor Compton
lecture series the second lecture by
Jack Gibbons
I'm Josh Cohen the department head in
political science and the department is
pleased and honored to be hosting Jack
Gibbons's visit to MIT as the Compton
lecturer
my responsibility today apart from doing
what I just did which is welcoming you
here and introducing myself is to
introduce the introducer four of Jack
Gibbons and that is jon deutsch jon
deutsches institut professor at MIT he's
served as director of the Central
Intelligence Agency from may 95 to
December 96 before that he was Deputy
Secretary of Defense and before that
Undersecretary of defense for
acquisition and technology he's also
served as director of energy research
acting assistant secretary for energy
technology and undersecretary in the US
Department of Energy in addition to all
of that he's been a member of the MIT
faculty since 1970 and served as the
chairman of the department of chemistry
the Dean of science and the provost he's
published a hundred and twenty technical
publications in physical chemistry as
well as numerous publications on
technology international security and
public policy issues but john deutsches
greatest distinction is that he was the
Provost when I got tenure here John
Thank You Josh for those compelling
sentences short and clear I'm delighted
to be here to introduce Jack Gibbons
Jack Gibbons is giving his second of
three Karl Compton lectures here at MIT
the third will be given in the spring at
a date yet to be announced this is the
second I have particular warmth for Karl
Compton lecture as having been the Karl
Compton professor here for many years
but it's a particular privilege to
introduce Jack Givens to you and it's
worthwhile to spend a moment briefly at
least on his career because it is
instructive for those of us who care
about educating people here at MIT jack
has had a quite broad career he began
actually nuclear physics where he was
for many years at the Oak Ridge National
Laboratory and I believe that's when I
first met him in the late 70s when I was
director of energy research for the
United States Department of Energy and
he also spent considerable time at the
University of Tennessee I'll come back
to this in a moment
in 1979 more or less he became a
director of the office of Technology
Assessment for the United States
Congress this is really I guess we have
to speak about in the past tense don't
worry quite quite regrettably this is an
experiment and good government it was in
fact a successful experiment good
government and that explains why it's no
longer there more or less but the office
of Technology Assessment was intended to
provide technical and objective to words
which are foreign to the patois in
Washington technical and objective
advice and counsel and information to
legislators on a wide range of subjects
that they had to address on Capitol Hill
and it did an enormous amount of
extremely you
full of valuable work and mostly it was
noted for its honesty and its
even-handedness at every issue that it
addressed a jack had at that office as I
said from 79 til 1993 when he became
President Clinton in the first term
President Clinton's science adviser he
served in that office for five years and
I think he served in that office with as
much dignity and as much honesty and
clarity is any prior occupant of that
office needless to say coming from
Tennessee coming from Oak Ridges he does
he was very close and a you might say a
lieutenant of Vice President Gore but
worked on a variety of issues throughout
the forest clinton term including what
is perhaps not widely known perhaps one
of the most important times of rebirth
of our support for federal support for
basic research in a large number of
departments throughout the federal
establishment noted notably NIH but Jack
did a splendid job and I had the
pleasure of working with him at that
time
what is special about Jack Gibbons you
know we here at MIT do you have lots of
people who are knowledgeable lots of
people who have vast experience lots of
people who have distinguished careers
and who know stuff that we should hear
but there's something unusual about Jack
Gibbons actually two unusual features
about Jack Gibbons it's important for us
people here at MIT who care about
technology and society who care about
how you give advice how you give
effective advice to government there are
two very special things about Jack
Givens the first is his integrity there
has never been a time that I've ever
heard in Washington and over 25 years
anybody say anything but the fact that
Jack Gibbons is clear and fair and
even-handed at how he makes his
technical judgments that is a rare
reputation to have I certainly lost my
reputation in that regard
a long time ago a very important and
something which I admire very much but
also the second important thing is the
Jack really invented a field there in
the early 70s in the remote area of
Tennessee and he invented a field which
we now call energy conservation or
energy productivity if you like but he
was the first person in the technical
community who took a systematic look at
the question about how to use energy
more efficiently and how to use energy
in a way to accomplish all those things
that we want energy to do for us with a
minimum of adverse effect on the economy
it is hard to realize how little work
had gone on on the area of energy
conservation before Jack started his
laboratory and his work in this area in
the early 70s down in Tennessee and has
kept it throughout his time at Oak Ridge
at the University of Tennessee and of
course at OTA so he has changed the way
people think about important science
technology issue namely the area of
energy conservation and that's something
to it I respect about him and that all
of us should strive for as a goal of
something we want to achieve
professionally to change the way people
think about an important technical or
scientific social life so social and
technical matter he's going to speak to
us today about a subject that there's no
person better qualified to speak to us
about the governance of Science and
Technology he's going to talk about
theory I thought that that section
should be relatively brief he's going to
talk about myth that section should be
rather large and he's going to talk
about reality about which no one knows
more I ask you to welcome my friend Jack
Gibbons
[Applause]
John that's a great pleasure to an honor
to be introduced by you to this this
audience here today
I've enjoyed many years of friendship
with John Deutsch and there's never been
a dull moment as those of you who know
John can attest I do remember and I
think I told John this once that I was
once told by a friend of mine about
biblical interpretations of academic
appointments and the statement was that
if the president of the university is
the Shepherd of the flock
then the Provost is the crook on his
staff and I'm not sure how you interpret
that but that that I think is this is
applicable if you're careful about the
meaning of words my first lecture what
had to do with the 21st century and the
kinds of questions about whether science
and technology would contribute to that
century or or scuttle its opportunities
we talked about the enormous
contributions that science and
technology have made in the 20th century
the regrettable consequences of as side
effects of some of those accomplishments
and also the mounting long-term issues
that now we see in front of us for the
21st century today rather than try to
prognosticate about the 21st century I'd
like to talk a bit about the processes
of forming and carrying out Science and
Technology Policy in other words it's
governance and I will try to enrich my
talk about process with some examples as
we go along and oh there'll be enough
time today to have a spirited
conversation and dialogue with you in
the audience historically and I think
it's important to keep this in a
historical context this nation has
always been characterized by a people
interested in exploration and in
discovery and invention
you can go back before the the
Declaration and certainly during the
development of the Constitution and find
full evidence of this and it's replete
through the years that have followed
that late 18th century time I think of
the bill of rights which talks about the
importance of protecting the and
encouraging the development of the
useful arts and set up that the process
for patenting as means of intellectual
property protection for inventors
I think of Jefferson sending his friend
Lewis and and Captain Clark to the West
to explore the West for the people to
try to understand our resources and
therefore be able to make fuller
utilization of them
I think of around the 1840s when Samuel
Morse went to the Congress and obtained
a grant from the government to build a
line of carrying a wire from Baltimore
to Washington so he could demonstrate
his new invention of telegraphy and that
was one of the first federal support
direct supports of the development of
technology I think of the land-grant
universities being established again in
the about the middle of the nineteenth
century not only to train and educate
but also to provide for agricultural
research and ultimately for its
extension out to the users of that
research I think of the development of
public health as a national means to try
to build the protection and capabilities
of our nation's health obviously defense
came along even more strongly in the
20th century the support of aviation
through the NACA and then its
transformation to NASA and and
incorporation of space exploration and
space sciences as a public adventure
of electronics throughout a variety of
the federal agencies s new means
electronics and computers new means to
increase our productivity and our access
to information and of course the
development of biotechnology all of
these are examples I think of eminently
successful joint ventures between public
and private interests in the further
development of our nation and the
development of options for us to achieve
our wants and needs
so governance of Science in these
earlier years arose out of a time in
which we shared a conviction that
Science and Technology were means to
ends that were desired by society and
therefore merited support by society
either through the encouragement and
protection of private activities or in
fact in addition the the incorporation
of public resources in that process but
during that time science was governed
largely by its own internal processes
which we still enjoy respect and must
covet today namely that we have an
internal discipline that it provides for
through credit our internal criticism
independent verification other means of
assuring that science remains healthy
and on target
I think it's illustrated is my mic still
on yes good bye a cartoon which you
should recognize as a as an essay in
pictures of the need for criticism of
one's ideas and for the insistence of a
continuity of thought when you're
developing an idea the continuity of
data or theory or what have you
John Locke said that basically the best
way to govern is to govern closest to
the place that needs governance and
within science in
eternal governance by our own capable
particular methods has been enormous ly
successful and has therefore enabled us
to move ahead without having a lot of
external governance applied to the
process of basic science it's a good
lesson that we would like to translate
to other things but are not as
successful that way now to make sure you
watch me instead of the board I'll turn
that off for a couple of minutes in
technology it was a different matter as
I said we started early by trying to
encourage and protect the development of
intellectual property we developed of
course over the years ideas of Health
and Safety as an over pinning to the
development of technology but around
World War two we came to a great
watershed of influence of Science and
Technology that was already revoluta ng
the country but I think the middle of
the night of the 20th century was it was
a turning point in terms of the total
impact of Science and Technology on our
national enterprise during the time of
Truman and Eisenhower we found the the
development of a an office within the
White House and the whole idea of
Science and Technology is becoming a
more and more central element in our
process of federal governance and even
an MIT of course has been very active
from that time onward in the in the
process of national policy and
governance in science and technology
many of our Bush another fellow from up
in this part of the country at by the
invitation of the president wrote an
essay on science the endless frontier
which helped set the case for science in
the post-war period as a means for
achieving a variety of national goals in
addition to defense its itself the
creation of the Science Foundation and
of mission oriented agencies
came out of that same period in which
the governance of Science and Technology
was taking full form and of course the
appointment of the science advisor a
critical step in the White House during
the post-war World War two period there
came a time of questioning about the how
how total the cornucopia was of the
developments from Science and Technology
atmospheric nuclear testing raised a lot
of concerns about whether we were doing
the right thing in that regard in terms
of radioactivity in the atmosphere
Rachel Carson and her essay on Silent
Spring was concerned about the extent to
which these long-lived pesticides were
in fact net positive for our society and
for the biosphere the there were many
arguments over the supersonic transport
which was a proposed plane to to bring
what someone at that time called a 21st
century sound to America while there
were some people who felt that the sonic
boom was not exactly a desirable 21st
century sound and there were other
concerns about environmental problems in
the upper atmosphere and so there was a
rising concern about whether or not we
were being careful enough not so much
with science but with the use of science
in various technological applications
Max Born about that time wrote that he
said intellect distinguishes between the
possible and the impossible reason
distinguishes between the sensible and
the senseless even the possible said
born can be senseless so there was this
rising concern about the need for more
careful governance a particularly of
technology in the in the closing decades
of the 20th century out of this came the
formation of the
of Technology assessment as John Deutz
mentioned to you in the early 70s as
Congress's attempt to create within its
own house a mechanism for focusing the
debates that had to do with Science and
Technology elevating the level of that
debate and providing the mostly
non-technical members of Congress with a
means to access the kind of information
they needed in order to carry out their
fiduciary responsibilities in the
governance of science that in fact OTA
found that in order to do this to be an
accepted and trusted party to both sides
of the aisle to both houses and to all
stakeholders with respect to technology
was indeed a great challenge and I
remember in 1980 this this little thing
has never seen the light of day before
incidentally we held an internal
exercise about how to organize in order
to carry out a technology assessment
that would be trustworthy and acceptable
to all the stakeholders not so much to
tell them what to do but what their
options were and to narrow the debate a
bit in the process we tried to talk
about organizations and I saved this the
sketch because I thought it's a funny
it's a kind of a humorous insight into
the way some of the OTA people thought
about the world and I hope you can see
that you will note and this is directly
from the original we sketched one
afternoon that there are various ways to
organize and they vary and they reflect
different cultures different nations and
you will note as you scan this I think
that the boxes tell you a lot about how
different people think about organizing
themselves in order to carry out work in
the middle is our ultimate sketch of
what we saw as OTAs organization namely
the birth the development and the
evolution of an assessment and you can't
read the fine print I can hardly read it
myself now but basically it entails
recognizing stakeholders and working
back and forth between analysis and
communication with Congress and
communication with stakeholders with
constant feedback and review processes
going on a lot of feedback criticism and
review until we finally had an output of
a meaningful product but I did want to
share this with you because the whole
process of carrying out an assessment
was something that took a long time to
learn how to develop so that one could
be assured of not only accuracy but also
trustworthiness of the information and
completeness of the of the illumination
of the issue so that all stakeholders
could find their best argument within
that document and therefore they could
all use it as a means for elevating the
debate
and by the time we really figured out
how to make it work course Congress
killed it and I'll get back to that
later on but about the same time OTA was
created the Office of Science and
Technology Policy was created by
Congress to be an office within the
White House it's actually a so-called
independent agent office it's not
exactly in the White House but it is
part of the White House now this came
about because the Congress that the time
was concerned about the lack of serious
attention being placed on science and
technology within the White House and so
they imposed this office formally into
the White House structure and and it was
it was meant by Congress to say we want
some kind of high-level advice and
capabilities for science analysis within
the White House within the executive
office of the president that later
evolved to be a part of this complex of
the president's science adviser and that
office itself and I think it's working
in in in an appropriate direction but it
is funny because in in taking the job
that I took and that Allan Bromley took
before me we actually had two
Commission's one as assistant to the
president for science and technology
which had begun in earlier times and
also director of the Office of Science
and Technology Policy now in the past
five years which I was of course more
familiar with than the years before in
terms of the White House the president
reestablished
and strengthened the Office of Science
and Technology Policy he enabled it to
integrate across the executive agencies
in a more policy level way by creating
the National Science and Technology
Council which gave the the office the
authority to develop presidential
decision memoranda and
executive orders this enabled us to
begin to pull the agencies together
across the the executive branch in a
more meaningful way to create in a sense
a kind of a virtual S&T department in
terms of picking out big programs inter
relating the relevant pieces across the
agencies and having them put together in
a more meaningful way in terms of the
budget and the programs they were
carrying out we also were able to
integrate the office across the White
House the other White House offices
which was very important because because
the national security the National
Domestic Policy the national economic
policy the National Environmental Policy
and the Office of Management and Budget
all have interlaced with between them a
bunch of Science and Technology so we
have to provide ways to pull these
offices together and in the chemists
language I think there is negative end
of all forces between these various
offices they tend to sort of separate
out unless you pull them together and by
this mechanism of the site of the of the
encouragement of the president we were
able to make joint appointments between
senior members of the of the Office of
Science Technology Policy with other
offices of the White House counsel's and
that made a big difference in terms of
us working together on issues rather
than in separate ways the president also
established to reestablish that
continued the work of the president
Science Advisory Committee the committee
of Advisors on science and technology
the president broadened the basis of
that committee by adding a substantial
number of people from private industry
as well as from universities and and the
the not-for-profit sector and and that
presence of senior level representation
from the private sector was very
important in terms of providing advice
to the president advice including in the
early
time some principles for the president
recommended to the president in the way
he think about he he would think about
science and technology in the nation's
future some principles about the
rationale for the engagement of the
federal government and its largesse in
the in the support of not only basic
science but Applied Science and the
development of generic technologies as
it were bridging between the traditional
support of fundamental science on the
part of the government and the and the
ultimate marketplace of Commerce and in
between those two polls there was a gap
that needed substantially bolstering and
the president has took the advice of the
Science Council in that regard the
effort of the National Science and
Technology Council transformed to the
development of some strategy papers that
were accepted by the President and
issued over his name papers that had to
do with the role of Technology in our
economic development with the the
science in the national interest another
as it were review of the question of the
support of science itself of the role of
Science and Technology as us as a key
strategy in our national security and a
broader sense not just of military
defense but also other other dynamics
that affect the stress level which can
lead to deadly conflicts over the
broadening of the notion of national
security and also technology as a role
in providing for environmental quality
at the same time having economic growth
with job creation we created a new sets
of partnerships between the public and
the private sectors involved in research
for instance in the the so called
partnership for a new generation of
vehicles which was a new very long
decade-long commitment on the part of
the public and the private sectors to a
joint venture
in advanced technologies relevant to the
creation of an automobile that would
serve as a number of public goals
including air pollution and dependence
on fossil fuels and lakes as well as
private goals of staying competitive in
a very very major industry the president
also used other mechanisms for assuring
that science and technology were
appropriately brought to bear on public
issues one was that he with the
assistance and cooperation of both
Republicans and Democrats in Congress
created the national bio ethics Advisory
Commission and this was took a while to
establish but it it became us formally
established just in time for dolly and
the cloning business to come along as
well as a number of other ethical issues
that we're beginning to emerge in this
issue of the governance of Science and
Technology and I think it's a good
example of where an attempt that failed
when attempted by the Congress and Al
Gore was wrapped up in that one and was
very much in favor trying it again down
in the executive branch and created as a
means to provide anticipatory capability
to wrestle with ethical issues in
science and technology in a way that was
thoughtful credible and therefore
accessible and usable by the by the
legislators the Congress meanwhile of
course was in the midst of the post Cold
War rationale there was an idea of what
what do we do with something that we
have supported in the past because it
defends us it helps us defend ourselves
and the world from the from the evil
empire what happens when the evil empire
disappears and there was a concern there
for about the most fundamental rationale
for major federal support of research
and Technology Science and Technology in
that post Cold War era this was
highlighted I think in and underscored
by the hundred and fourth Congress
back in 1995 and 96 which had the mood
of simply cutting government because
anything that could cut the size of
government was bound to be a good not a
bad and a lot of arguments came up at
that time about what is the appropriate
federal role for Science and Technology
in the post-cold war world the memos
from the president Science Advisory
Committee were very helpful to the
president at that time in making the
defense and the rationalization for this
continued support of these in this in
specifically as as appropriate to a
variety of national overarching national
goals industry came forward strongly at
that time as another factor or voice in
the governance of Science and Technology
in the form for example of a number of
very large newspaper ads that were
brought out signed by a large number of
captains of very diverse American
industries urging Congress to support
science especially I was happy
especially university-based research as
means to achieve national ends the power
of the private sector coming in and not
asking for money but asking the federal
government to support university
research in higher education was a very
telling made a very telling impact on
the members of Congress as they
delivered whether or not they should cut
science about 30 percent or research
about 30 percent or that order so
industry itself then played a role in F
affecting the way Science and Technology
were governed the perspective of how
they should be governed and in what way
and that canaima also came forward
neither your own president vest was very
effective along with a number of other
university presidents in trying to
clarify with the congress that had not
really thought this much about these
issues about the importance of of
science and technology as an integral
part of the higher education process and
and the combined impact of those
activities on the future of our nation
in terms of developing our options later
in the not the hundred and fourth but
with the 115 Congress decided they
should look again at this issue of
science in the national interest and a
the only PhD physicist in the house Vern
Ehlers a Republican from Minnesota
undertook under the direction of
chairman Sensenbrenner a another
analysis of so-called national science
policy study which was completed earlier
this year and it essentially reiterated
the earlier and was very compatible with
the bullets President Clinton's own
notions of this public support of
Science and Technology
what elders did was point out that some
of the more underrepresented groups in
our society for instance the smaller
universities the rural universities
merited more support in terms of
research but by and large this document
was accepted by Congress by resolution
and we saw that as one key milestone in
the reconciliation between the great
struggles that the administration had
with Congress in the hundred fourth
Congress and it's coming back around to
the reestablishment of at least a
seemingly full bipartisan strong support
for research in future years a most
pleasant seeming turnaround of events at
the same time we saw conversations in
Congress about it's not exactly esoteric
governance of Science and Technology but
the word was let's double the budget
well let you know that's sort of a
bottom line isn't it let's double the
budget for science in the Congress what
they didn't say was how soon some talked
about doubling the budget in five years
others 10 or 12 years so the number was
not but the number was not so important
as the direct explicit implication that
the Congress had come
terms with the value of public support
of research and technology and was
committed to long-term investment in
this direction which is very counter to
what had happened only a few years
before tells you another lesson about
the governance of science and technology
there are some long term underpinning
underpinnings of support of this in our
nation but they are subject to two
near-term shifts of focus and attention
and values and that's a clarion call to
those of us in the community not to
assume anything
one must can constantly reacquaint
people with the relevance of what we do
to the overarching national goals and
needs of our people let's see I
mentioned the establishment of the
National bio ethics Advisory Committee
is yet another example of what we had
done now what's happened with respect to
the doubling of the budget is that there
is a resolution that says we will double
the budget for research the the number
spoken by some members urged on early
was let's double it in five years others
said 10 years I think the final
resolution says 12 years and you know
what 12 years doubling means it's about
what about 6% per year now that's a
good-sized number that's twice the GNP
growth rate but it's not it's not a
massive change in things and let me tell
you why that's even that I think is an
important number it's an important
number because if you look at what has
to happen with the federal budget namely
our agreements to move toward balance
and the power of the budget committees
to do so and if you look at the makeup
of the so-called
budget itself which is divided between
entitlement programs which includes
Social Security Medicare a number of the
other programs that are instituted by
and then look at the discretionary
programs which is really you can divide
between defense discretionary and all
the rest of non-military discretionary
budget and the federal interest the
payment payment on the debt which of
course has has tripled under the in the
Reagan years and is therefore now a very
significant part of our total budget you
see that over time the entitlement
programs and the interest on national
debt have risen to the point of
competing with the so-called
discretionary programs and that the
non-defense discretionary programs now
have reduced from about one-sixth of our
budget to about one seventh of the
budget so there's a constant squeeze on
those resources that have to be taken
into account anytime you talk about
change in science policy or the
supportive of Science and Technology and
now I want to speak a little bit about
the budget maybe I almost ought to leave
that up there so we can memorize it
before the end of the afternoon I'll
leave it there a little bit longer
because the budget is where the battle
is ultimately joined and in the course
in the Constitution the name of the game
is that the president proposes and the
Congress disposes that's a that's a it's
an old saying but nonetheless true that
that's what the theory is in reality as
we look at these annual cycles of the
budget and let's just go through that
very quickly the State of the Union I
think we're all familiar with when does
it happen what time of the year January
thank you dr. Deutsch I was looking at
the students but he knows he knows the
territory the State of the Union is both
the end of a process and the beginning
of a cycle and so let's start a year
earlier than the
state of the union and see what happens
in the late winter especially in March
the Office of Management and Budget
starts sending its initial marks or
dollars assignment to the various
agencies influenced in detail at least
by the president's sense of urgency and
of priority now remember budgets never
change
revolutionary wise they change
incremental II but they do change so in
the late winter we have these first
marks going out to the federal agencies
instructions as it were for the agencies
to take this number and figure out how
they can spend it with the highest yield
and best reflection of the president's
prerogatives around April other
instructions are sent to the heads of
agencies for example we instituted when
I got no and I was so with Leon Panetta
as head of the officer management budget
an annual memorandum that went to the
heads of agencies to talk about the
science and technology parts of their
budgets and to provide them with a
reminder of where the president stands
on these issues and the and the special
need for priorities both for individual
programs as well as for those programs
that cut across the agencies that's
around April by mid summer the agencies
have to take all this information and
crank it back through their own planning
process to develop a submission back to
the office of management and budget for
their detailed agency proposal typically
the agencies came back with budgets that
were larger than the numbers assigned to
them by OMB that's almost an annual
ritual which later causes the agency
heads to interact with OMB n with the
president so the agency submissions come
in to the OMB in the summertime and
we're upon a number of conferences of
our so called pass back meetings happen
between the agencies and the OMB and the
OMB is joined by for instance members of
the Office of Science and Technology
Policy with respect to Science and
Technology parts of these budgets and so
this is an interaction of OMB the Office
of Science Technology Policy the council
Environmental Quality the National
Economic Council you can name it other
White House offices that all coal join
and working with the agencies to try to
make sure that their budget reflects the
priorities as seen by the White House
offices the military in this activity is
can be seen as a kind of a place apart
it has less of the sort of breadth of
involvement of the White House than the
other so-called domestic agencies but
I'll talk about that more after a while
in the late fall we begin to pull all
the pieces together and there are
appeals made back and forth between what
OMB and the White House offices say on
the one hand what the agencies say and
of course the cabinet officers can
appeal directly to the president if they
need to during that time but there's a
lot of horse trading that goes on during
that period engaged as it moves toward a
final decision about the budget begins
to engage fewer and fewer people within
the White House because as you get close
to the ultimate decisions about a budget
that has to be done ultimately by the
president it moves from a time in which
a lot of the White House offices are
deeply involved to a time in which
perhaps a half a dozen people or less
are involved and ultimately between the
president and and he uses the vice
president in this in the case of
President Clinton he uses Bob Rubin as
secretary of the Treasury Gene Sperling
who is basically a chief domestic policy
counselor
and the chief of staff as his to a
degree the rest of us but mostly a
smaller smaller group of people to
wrestle was putting all these pieces
together to find a budget that's going
to be manageable and defensible his
final decisions are made basically
during the month of December and because
by the end of December
the budget has to be ready to be put
together the pieces are written for the
federal budget and in January goes to
the printer in term and time and in time
for the State of the Union and then
after the State of the Union comes the
process of selling this budget defending
the budget before the Congress as they
go through their rituals of hearings and
and consideration of the budget itself
which in turn take the spring and the
summer and sometimes the fall and
sometimes it goes right on through the
yard so you have a continuing resolution
you don't even have a budget but in the
process of those hearings again the
governance of Science and Technology is
being tested the president has proposed
the Congress disposes and remember that
the Congress has other constraints they
not only hear the President's budget but
within the Congress they start with an
overall budget number and then they
decide how they are going to allocate
this so called 602 allocations of the
whole pie off to the different different
appropriations committees now the
committee's that have a lot to do with
science which in one committee a
subcommittee of appropriations has the
Science Foundation the NASA EPA the
office of the and little things like the
Office of Science and Technology Policy
and the Veterans Administration and the
Housing and Urban Development
Administration so we have mixtures of
very powerful agencies like veterans and
housing admixed with science agencies
all having to be squeezed into one
single pot in alerts we aren't trading
something this kind of science for that
kind of science but we're trading
between housing and science or veterans
in science and other parts of science
are competing again with other national
priorities so there's no bucket for
science you have to understand the
organization of these appropriations
committees in order to understand the
dynamics of defending the budget and of
trying to help effect the process the I
think for the record for the past five
or six years is pretty
instructive first of all the in
governance the underpinnings I think are
pretty constant we do have a nation that
supports research is interested in
research is committed to the idea that
one can have jobs and a growing economy
and that at the same time be secure in
international security sense as well as
healthy and with it with a healthy
environment but in practice we have to
deal with change in other words
governance in this area as it in all
other areas of governance is a process
it's not written in stone
well what lessons first of all I think
one lesson that is I'm constantly aware
of is that our society does have this
enduring optimism about the rewards of
science and technology but increasingly
it's saying we must not take for granted
that these rewards are all going to be
the returns are all going to be positive
especially as it has become more
pervasive in our international lives
secondly as George Brown said with
respect to Vern Ehlers paper on science
policy he said what's missing here is
the imperative to link the investments
in science and technology to the social
purposes being served and there he feels
and I tend to agree with him and I know
the President Clinton does there he
feels we're coming up short it's
important in other words to relate
science and technology to societal goals
you know in the private sector
consideration of Science and Technology
is a little bit easier it has a very
strong market discipline that acts on
its decisions and that market discipline
in turn reflects largely reflects
society's concerns but the public sector
is more complex we don't have the
equivalent of a market place discipline
so we've developed things like the
government performance and results Act
which was created by Congress to try to
constantly evaluate the value of
our various investments the problem of
this with especially with respect to
science is that you can evaluate the
process of science quite well thank you
but only retrospectively you can
determine only by looking backwards how
well you've done and it's very difficult
if not impossible to determine looking
forward how you're going to do so that's
an that's a puts it in a sort of a
separate class of of interesting
challenges how can we evaluate and
persuade our benefactors the American
people about the value of making these
investments in research if we can't tell
them what's going to happen and and I
don't think we should try to tell them
what's going to happen in detail but
rather look backward and say here's
what's happened in the past and here's
why we are confident therefore will
happen in the future there we got a lot
of help from the Council of Economic
Advisors in this regard in which they
non technologists look backward at the
role of research in America's economy
and found an extraordinary rate of
return
however uncertain but an extraordinary
rate of return ultimately of these
investments in terms of the return of
the public investment this the so that's
the second thing is that we have to make
sure we relate science and technology to
societal goals the third lesson not to
me is and this is multi factored but
it's important several several things
are important one is it's really
important to know the territory the
whole organization the whole process the
whole rhythms of governance are
important to understand in order to be
able to affect it in a positive way why
for instance is a department of idea of
science probably a very bad idea when
you look at the way we're organized and
do things why is it that there is no
science kitty why is it that that
happens and how can we how can we
accommodate for that or take that into
account as we try to help affect us
science policy and and
governance how to use that information
in other words to inform the debate and
help evolve an ever more rational and
and productive system of governance the
importance of compromise
I remember one outstanding senator
telling me when I was at OTA once he
said Jack out we were gonna ask you
about doing this particular analysis for
us but now it's too late
in other words the decision hadn't been
made but the influence of the scientific
analysis was simply beyond the pale that
had gone on to the more overarching
political decisions that have to be made
about about the issue that that he was
talking about in the failure of the
super the superconducting supercollider
we found another thing namely not only
know the territory but also know the
importance of compromise just like this
it's too late for analysis in this case
we found that the defense of the
superconducting supercollider was was
was not going to work for a variety of
reasons and that it was going to go down
even though the administration supported
it in 93 but as a consequence we were
able to recognize the importance of
compromise here not try to fight that
decision but rather to use it as a means
to engender support for both the B
Factory the be messin Factory which is
being built at Stanford and also for the
u.s. joining the European community in
support of the Large Hadron Collider so
I think that's a lesson to worry if life
gives you lemons then try to make
lemonade from it the space station was
another example that I'm still
confounded with I believe but here was
one in which we were again handed as one
administration went to another
administration we were handed a project
with a lot of
meant them to it a project that involved
the same sort of problems of the of the
downscaling of federal activities in
various regions of the nation and our
attempts to try to help buffer that rate
of change of the federal government
retreating from certain areas and the
opportunity to bring Russia into what
once had been the symbol of standoff
between the free world and the evil
empire to a place in which they were Co
joined and the largest technical
activity or technology high-technology
activity error attempted in peacetime
and so again a bunch of compromises went
about in order to a the resolve the
Space Station decision as it came about
and I'll be happy to go into this later
if you want to the international
thermonuclear energy reactor is another
case where fusion research which is
important as a long-term option because
we just don't have written that many
options was focused unfortunately on
trying to build a very large machine as
the next round in thermonuclear fusion
research and it was internationalized
the the greatest value of that whole
activity I think was the fact that it
was an internationalized activity but we
had to devise a way to move from an
impossible commitment at the politically
impossible commitment to help
participate in building such a big
machine and move it to transform the
activity keeping it international but
moving it toward plasma physics
materials science is relevant to plasma
high temperature plasmas and the likes
and that's what we're in the process of
doing now again a compromise with the
the high on highly unlikely up the
possibility that we would build such an
enormous machine at this point in time
and I would say for instance again that
MIT had I make plate of an important
role in the government and the people
understanding that it may well be
premature to try to build a big machine
yet until we know more about the physics
and the chemistry and the material
sciences
related to fusion and plasmas so again I
think we found a budget now find a
budget that was sustained for fusion and
plasma research but with this emphasis
shifted away from a big machine and more
appropriately toward a broad age ranging
area of research and finally another
example of of the importance of for
company for compromise was that the
administration was approached with
almost de facto legislation from the
farm belt community from the Corn Belt
community that we would do a genome of
the corn plant and under tact undertake
that directly we were able to persuade
Congress generally that the way if you
really want to get the corn genome for
good cause the place to start is not
with corn but with the lowly mustard
plant because that enables you to build
up toward the more complex plant and
probably get there better and faster and
certainly thus expensively so by
compromising with their desire to get
the corn genome we were able to mount a
multi-agency program on on plant genome
it's also important to be prepared
because government acts in response to
something as Adlai Stevenson once said
America never seems to see the
handwriting on the wall until their back
is up against the wall or at least they
perceive that and so I learned a lesson
from a man from the National Institutes
of Health named Jim Shannon once though
always when he was up with Congress
carried in his briefcase at least one or
two really good ideas about how to spend
more money at the NIH and frequently
having that thoughtful information
immediately available when a question
came up or a perceived crisis occurred
enabled Shannon to do a magnificent job
of expanding the activities of the NIH
during the Arab oil embargo in nineteen
in 1973 which was a sudden crisis on on
America a lot of foolish decisions were
made but we were able over the course of
one week
to put together information we'd been
working on which enabled us to move
quickly toward passing a a speed limit
law on the open highways and a right
turn on red law on the in urban areas so
that we could slow down the very fast
traffic which was less my lead a less
fuel-efficient and speed up the slow
traffic which would help urban air
pollution and and mileage in town and we
were able to do it over a weekend had we
not had the crisis or the time the
information available during that crisis
it would not have been able to happen
Minh other-- lesson I learned from OTA
was what to do in in terms of a very
large administration dramatic
recommendation in this case it was
recommended I think by a vice president
Rockefeller that we have a hundred
billion dollar program force in fuels
development and we developed at OTA
testimony over basically over a weekend
based on what work we had done to show
that this would indeed be folly to try
to commit to that kind of production in
a technology that was not that well
developed and we were informed the
following week by the key committee that
our testimony had persuaded them it was
not a good thing to do and it helped
massively downscale the so-called sin
fuels program and finally we were asked
in one point about the utility of of
space-based ballistic missile
interception immediately following
president reagan's declaration of the
so-called star wars program and we had
we had anticipated some of this and had
done some work and were able to deliver
to the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee testimony which basically
through a very very serious questions
into the technical feasibility of this
proposal which in turn slowed down the
process and got the White House of
course quite mad at OTC to respond
authoritative ly and quickly
was was key in that process well another
important thing I think is to expect
surprises and deal with them as best you
can
one two examples one is the Mars Rock
which we found out about when Dan gold
and met me in the country and whispered
to me what was going on and this was the
discovery of a meteorite in Antarctica
which was very careful and very
fascinating microchemical and physical
examinations seemed to bear some
evidence of possible early life and it
was almost for sure a rock from Mars the
way we had to handle that in terms of
having the president being engaged in it
and saying the right words about the
process of science rather than take
advice from one at least one of his more
powerful political advisers namely who
wanted the President to announce that he
was going to decide to send people to
Mars to investigate this told us again
and that took us 24 hours to turn around
but it tells you again that the name of
the game at least in the White House is
not in science and technology governance
is not so much hits or runs in the game
it's saves to keep things from happening
red that shouldn't happen another of
course was Dali that sudden announcement
caused a flurry of activities and
careful work between Harold Varmus the
head of the National Institutes of
Health and myself and others at the
White House enabled the White House to
take a position which was thoughtfully
developed had just the right words in it
to to head off what would have been
could have been some disastrous
constraints put on biomedical research
but on the part of an overzealous
Congress trying to respond to that
situation so timing is terribly
important and I think now there's a new
and thorny issue before us
not only in terms of the relatively new
issues of of the ethics and that is of
intergenerational governance governance
of science of technology with
intergenerational issues taken into
account and I think one only need think
about climate change issues of global
biodiversity global population issues as
those things that are intrinsically
exactly and and very importantly
intergenerational in nature and and
things that we haven't really faced
substantially before in the century that
I think we're gonna have to learn how to
deal with in the coming decade and
finally pick your shots I'll give you an
example within the in the White House
especially post Jerry Wiesner working
with respect to the Department of
Defense is of is a place where you have
to pick your shots it's a it's a very
large elephant and and therefore you
can't try to tackle the whole album that
rather picked those things that are most
appropriate for to do in science and
technology policy some three things that
happen during my time at the White House
resulted and I'm pleased to say all
three worked out pretty well with the
department one was the ending of nuclear
weapons testing and the and the coupled
decision to support the idea of our
nuclear stockpile stewardship program
which in turn enabled us we believe to
convince people that we knew how to
maintain a trustworthy weapons stockpile
without having to do a continuation of
nuclear testing but the cost of that was
to provide other means non explosive
means for doing this testing that in
turn enabled us to maintain and take a
leadership in the global push for the
Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty second is
with respect to defense was the
convergence process which
was very much a part of along with some
of the rest of us namely to find those
places where military and civil needs
could be merged rather than being
carried out separately at much higher
cost and we were able to merge those
interests with respects of the global
positioning satellite system with
respect to weather satellites and with
respect to space launch capabilities
those are but three areas in which we
were able to Co join the domestic and
military programs to save a lot of money
in the process and hopefully succeed the
final one was in most recent budget I
have to deal with was support for the
the basic and applied research programs
in the Department of Defense so-called
6.1 and 6.2 programs in which we
determined fairly late in the process of
the 99 budget that the department was
seen to be getting ready to come in with
much lower numbers for those two areas
because the services were more
interested especially certain of the
services we're more interested in
acquiring hardware and and other things
related to current readiness rather than
these very long-term research activities
which are not that much on the on the
agenda of of the services generals who
have a relatively shorter time interest
in their future it's sort of like a CEO
of a company whose products are becoming
less and fairly quickly but long
compared to their reward enable you the
next quarter of the the value of their
stock so they're necessarily focused in
the short-term the same for some of the
services we were able from the from the
White House to spot this to talk with
the office of Secretary of Defense and
through and it happened more than once
and in each case the secretary
understood the absolute essential nature
of supporting the basic and applied
research programs from within the
department and those numbers were
restored and we're very grateful for
that
so you have to pick your shots and
and if you do so you can you can win
most of them well what's my final
conclusion I think science and discovery
enables us to develop options that in
turn will enable a desired future to
emerge if we choose it antoine santa
azul breeze once said that i think this
is from the little prince he said your
job is not to predict the future but to
enable it and that i think is the task
of the science and technology community
to enable those overarching national
goals and needs to it be achieved and
lastly i think a conclusion is that we
have a newfound perspective of the power
of science and technology in our present
and future lives
indeed that power gives us as someone
said both the promises of heaven and the
perils of hell and that reality means
that governance will forever be with us
in this very powerful medium but also we
must have eternal vigilance especially
from within the community to assure that
the debate is is elevated is level and
is one in which we can participate not
necessarily as members of congress but
as concerned and informed citizens
that's the end of my preaching for today
i want to thank you for your attention i
didn't see a single soul sleeping and
i'm astonished and i'm ready to be
attacked thank you
okay now while I go over here to turn
off my slide do you have any comments or
questions anyone want to go into
political science let's start here and
then your second yeah well I think PhDs
have a special requirement because they
have had the good fortune of not only
having good minds but also being able to
exercise them and achieve an advanced
degree so they have special
responsibilities inherently incumbent on
them to be full citizens and that is to
use that wisdom to help inform the
debate and to help raise the level of
awareness in our society Madison said
that if we want to be our own governors
we have to use the power that knowledge
gives us and knowledge gives you a
special amount of power and you don't
have to wait till you finish your PhD to
begin to exercise that in the issues of
Public Policy there are other ways once
you finish I for instance got into
policy not right away fortunately but I
did research for number of years and
then I moved toward policy because I had
that extra experience of knowing what
it's like to be at the bench to be part
of discovery and it became a fascinating
thing to me because a lot more difficult
than doing physics but there are
postdoctoral fellowships to work on the
Committees of Congress there are there
are or in on the staffs of some of the
members we now have two PhD members of
the house instead of one that's 100%
inquiry that's pretty good start on top
of George Brown so there are a variety
of mechanisms but I would say the first
thing to do is to equip yourself with
not only the technical skills that you
have but to constantly think and read
about the relevance of those skills
broadly to the issues before the public
and as the president said think about a
homeowner and what their concerns are
and how do those can
CERN's relate to the kinds of tools of
opportunities that science and
technologies bring to them all too
frequently they're two separate it's
easy to do with health
that's why NIH gets so readily supported
it's tougher to do with some of the
other areas we're working in but
nonetheless valid and important in fact
Harold Varmus in the Roosevelt Room a
year ago not not even a year ago stood
up when we were having a meeting on the
budget and made a wonderful defense not
of his budget but of this National
Science Foundation budget because he
said we've got to have that support if
we expect to move ahead in biomedicine
and the president picked up on this and
talked about it at the 150th anniversary
of the Triple A yes it's that it's that
sense of of the importance of all of
science in order to move ahead on some
particular area in this case biomedicine
but it's a hard sell it's one we have to
continue to work on and understand that
it's not widely known about the
relevance of science to people's
individuals lives not as widely known as
as we need for it to be yes why can't we
have a guarantee and just have that give
it to us for five years well there are
precedents to this for instance when you
build a new aircraft carrier you commit
to the whole thing and then you and that
sort of puts the Congress on line to say
in the succeeding years we're going to
commit and make these necessary
appropriations it's never really been
carried over to large scientific
projects in that sense but Congress is
moving in the direction of wanting to
budget by project rather than by year by
year things the problem on the SSC was
not so
watch its total expenditure which was
large but the fact that it was not on
schedule they were running into some
problems with some of the mega some of
the magnets and it was an at u.s.
national effort it had not been
internationalized and when we got into
office that we couldn't internationalize
it that fast and it was esoteric I
remember defending that budget in front
of a Senate committee and I tried to use
every analogy I could think of I said
look this isn't accelerator but it's a
it's really a microscope because you're
looking at the smallest particles it's
also a telescope because you're looking
out toward heavenly bodies and trying to
understand some of the very energetic
events it's also a time machine because
it takes you back to the very high
energy associated with the origin of the
universe and I got all excited and that
didn't do much good because the Congress
have decided that this was big science
it was a big expenditure it was a very
esoteric they didn't see its
relationship to the overarching goals of
health environment security and it was
too distant just too distant and it's
it's very sad and we could go on on that
one but you want a quick follow-up with
distant research based projects
or research ideas that have had
practical applications 40 or 50 or 60
years down Lamy you can glue everything
from Einstein's theory of relativity
you know application using GPS know why
no one thought he didn't think that he
didn't know at the time that well if I
think it was this theory then you you're
absolutely right and it's important not
to say it once but remember Congress
turns over very frequently and there are
new faces there some of the staff turns
over about 50 percent per year so it's a
constant education process but there
there are frequent alloc not only
allegations but references to the fact
that if you look at the work done at
least a Nobel Prizes the time that the
lag time there is typically now like two
decades with exceptions obviously but it
is important to understand that you
can't tell now exactly where things are
going to lead but remember the SSC was
very popular with its idea with its the
notion it was going to be built over
time there was a great contest across
the country for consortium of
universities and states to get together
and bid for this accelerator ere all
Congress was in favor of that because
they all came from at least one state as
soon as it focused on one state namely
Texas forget it the rest really weren't
all that interested because they didn't
associate that facility with benefits to
their state they could have they should
have if they'd understood that it would
be a place where their scientists could
operate as well not just a place where
it happened to be located
but that wasn't done and that's a that's
an issue of thinking about establishing
the value of a capital commitment in one
place to other states within the whole
country now what's going on right now
for instance I think is a better shot at
it where we're trying to build an
advanced neutron source for a variety of
neutron diffraction stuff cliffs all
here was one of the early
well Nobel laureate
engaged in Neutron diffraction it's a
tool of studying condensed matter
physics of studying biological molecules
all sorts of things but you can only
build one of these things they're very
expensive and we they finally settled on
the both the facility which will be an
accelerator rather than an than a
nuclear reactor and will be located at
Oak Ridge because not because that's
where vice president's from but but
because that's where we have a very
large National Laboratory deeply engaged
in this work over years that and it's
the it's the only of the big national
laboratories that doesn't have some big
facility in it so here we're trying to
build the case that this facility we're
ever located has enormous importance to
the nation not just in basic research
but also by industry and we hope that by
that means Congress will continue to
fund the project itself and the most
recent vote was that they intend to do
that
yes and I wonder if it's not widely
known simply because we as scientists
tend to separate ourselves from the rest
of the community and that we don't sit
and really think about what the impact
our research and our inventions or
whatever else that we do will actually
have on the society and the community
that we live in and I wonder if
you see anyway like through education
say here at MIT or at any other
institution where we could really
encourage scientists and students to
really think about all of those things
while we're in our research because we
tend to kind of forget about the rest of
the community and that's why there's
that separation between scientists and
non-scientists I think so I think it's
it's a process that has to go on like
education for all of your life but I
think an awareness level raising of the
importance of doing this for our own
sake at all but it also is a part of our
job is something we need to work on
that's one reason I'm up here this fall
yeah where'd he go wrong John the OTA
was agile and efficient pocket inside of
the huge morass now it's gone what do
you see as other agencies that are agile
well there are pockets of agility here
and there no question about it and I
think what Vice President Gore has been
trying to do is to maximize those
minimize some of the rest by the so
called reinventing government but OTA
fell not because it was ineffective but
for two reasons one is Congress needed a
scalp because they were cutting budgets
everywhere and of all the congressional
offices I think other than a an
arboretum somewhere OTA was the smallest
and politically the least capable to
defend itself politically he's capable
because it was science and you know
science is very far away from most
political lives secondly the other
agencies served all of Congress not just
committee chairs and thirdly and this I
think is is probably to a degree
legitimate although not wholly so there
was a perception at least that OTAs work
took too long that issues that they
couldn't get an answer fast enough for
their needs within the pulse of the
Congress I think that was wrong but that
was a perception and finally there was a
need there was a felt condition on the
part of those conservatives that OTA was
too liberal and if it mostly relates
back to the Star Wars fight we got into
some people even called the demise of
OTA as Reagan's revenge and I think
again the facts of the matter are that
that it was it cannot be labeled as
either liberal or conservative because
we always gave the best arguments to
both sides but that nonetheless was part
of the argument whether one could ever
recreate OTA I don't know I do know that
there's a Republican member of Congress
amo houghton who used to run corning
glass before he ran for congress who has
been desperately trying to reestablish
something like an OTA and they're
waiting for someone to come up with a
good idea about how to recreate that
capability for the congress it's not
going to happen
than the Library of Congress or the
generous Accounting Office partment the
General Accounting Office because it
simply they aren't organized the way you
have to get organized to do it there's
well there are some attempts one is to
try to shape the academy of engineering
the academy of sciences to do some of
this partly possible but not not wholly
satisfactory because you have to be you
need to be a part of the family in order
to be involved in it another is to have
places like MIT that have enormous
capabilities at least a latent
capability to rapidly respond
authoritative lead to issues that could
be better tapped especially by those
members within their purview their
region and I think that may be a great
hope for the nation is for the
university community to somehow organize
itself to be able to be more responsive
to queries to get a little closer to the
members and if you're closer to the
members and the senior staff you're more
likely to get asked those questions or
be brought into the arguments yes
but a reputation for having a
comparatively poor science education and
primary and secondary school level I'm
wondering if anybody any of the
advocates yes very much so both in
Congress and in the and the
administration and in the state houses I
think we do have a woeful situation in
our k12 system and the nation we're
obviously working very hard at that now
in in capable teachers as well as you
know bringing in capabilities such as
access to information technology access
to improve the process of learning of
the effectiveness of the learning system
and we have a long way to go it is by
the skin of our teeth that somehow
magically despite this woeful woefully
inadequate preparation we still managed
to do very well when we get to the
undergraduate and especially the
graduate years so we need to hold on to
the best and not take it for granted
like MIT but at the same time focus hard
on k12 I was very dispiriting the other
day when the president of the National
Academy of Sciences told me that his
daughter had finished a PhD in
biochemistry and to the great angst of
her department faculty that she had
graduated from she decided to go into
high school teaching of science and and
her father Bruce Alberts was furious at
the Department for denigrating the idea
that a fresh PhD might deign themselves
to try to teach high school science I
say she ought to have a medal I've kept
you longer than we should we're gonna
have a reception is that right and I
know it john deutsch is out a sickbed to
be here and i think the rest of you
deserve a break so I want to thank you
for inviting for coming to hear me for
the second time we'll do one more time
in the spring thank you very much
you